in Virginia
hey Gregory how are you I'm good how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up all right so I've read through the
Total Money Makeover I tell you is
probably one of the best books I read
prob about two and a half years ago
thank you
and I am a hundred percent on board you
know a great message is exactly what we
needed the problem is I can't get my
wife on board so I can give you two and
a half years worth of excuses so I mean
I've tried everything you know that the
book says so I guess it's a two-part
question is there stuff I can try to
encourage her to get on board and then
if not is there a way to move through
the baby steps and build well with your
spouse not on board no the second one I
would not attempt to do number one I
don't have any data points in any of our
experience or research that indicates
you're going to be successful with that
dragging your spouse kicking and
screaming almost never leads to
millionaire status so I'm going to move
away from that one real quick so this
really comes down to a marriage question
there's really what it comes down to now
sometimes what guys do and I know I have
done this many times because I am a
task-oriented fool I see a task I go to
the task and really don't care much
about anything else but I get the test
done I'm just driven that way so
sometimes what I've done with my wife
Sharon is I come in and start talking
about what and how we're gonna do
something before I shared with her why I
wanted to do it and why it would be good
for us if I do the why ahead of time
which is the better version of Dave I
usually get her on board but if I come
in and go hey I just read this new book
we're gonna sell your car that usually
goes over like not at all okay and so I
don't know to the extent you did that
but if you did do that that would make
you like a normal guy and you may want
to start restart the conversation with
an Apollo
because you do over one if you did that
what do you think she does not like to
hear Dave Ramsey in the house say there
you are see you've been you've been
turned you don't turn me into a cuss
word dude look at you so but it's
because you've been telling her all
these restrictive things we're gonna get
on a budget we're gonna cut up the
credit cards we're gonna get out of debt
instead of why hmm
you already know you're why you know why
you want to do it so you're willing to
do the sacrifice but sacrificing or
engaging in pain without a good reason
is a mental illness no one would do that
so you only would engage in pain if it
gives you a greater good I don't want to
live like no one else unless I get to
later live and give like no one else
there has to be a payoff on the other
side and that's the why so what is it
that gets her excited in the future if
you were debt-free and had a big pile of
money what would be her favorite thing
to do traveling you know is after I've
tried that because she wants to move to
the beach yes so I tried to give her the
goal hey this is this is our goal we
want to be able to move to the beach one
day here's what we need to do to get
there and then is that doesn't you know
it's a good conversation but there was
no action after after the conversation
Gregory have you sat down and said I'm
scared
with all this debt have you been
vulnerable I've it's rare that you sit
down with a marriage partner and I mean
this is Dave was just hit this nail on
the head saying it hurts for me to keep
doing it like this this this the karien
debt scares me look around what's going
on right now those who are not leveraged
have a much better shot of getting out
with fewer bruises on the back end of
this what's going on right now when you
sit down with your with your spouse and
you talk from a place of vulnerability
man it that can be unnerving on your end
because she might say I don't care and
now you got another problem right but at
least you're putting your why on the
table and being honest have you have you
done that if you sit down with her that
way oh yes roundabout phone
yeah husband roundabout means gnarly not
really yeah well we've sat down and gone
over you know listed all our dead yeah
that's - over a budget but it's not
those are tactics you know that's what
and how that is not why and so it needs
to be that you spend your you have gone
III think you've done what I'm talking
about more than you realize just
listening to Yahoo I you know and I
don't think you ever need to say Dave
Ramsey again in your house because I'm
not the problem and I'm also not the
solution the you figure out why you're
willing to sacrifice to win and both of
you get out of why that you're willing
to do that and then you do the tactical
sacrifices to win and and that's the the
process if you can't do that and you're
starting to throw up your hands even in
our conversation and discussed this is
not going to go well in your marriage so
you you may need to sit down in marriage
counselor
are we your pastor and try to get her to
hear you you guys are you're speaking
two different languages and you're not
you're not communicating you're both
making a lot of noise but there's not
real communication communication means
you were understood and you understand
and you have not been understood and I'm
not sure you really understand either
one so that that's what you you guys
need some help walking through this and
by the way I don't know of many
long-term really high-quality marriages
that at some point didn't have someone
walk with him a little while and help
him work through some rough patches
absolutely that's pretty much standard
fare absolutely I know it we've been
married almost 40 years but the 10-year
mark we just about had two hillbillies
killing each other it was
I mean she's from the hills of East
Tennessee frying-pan throwing there's an
Olympic event so I mean it was it was
ugly but and a great wonderful marriage
counselor filled with God's Spirit came
into our life and you know changed their
life and by the way she's still a good
friend of ours mmm this day that lady is
and that's my hope we go to the dentist
a couple of times a year we talked to
our pastor a few times a year we you
know you go to the doctor once or twice
like make
this apart of your having somebody with
you because I I I don't think we gave
you the answer that that I didn't hear
the light bulb come on over your head so
you're gonna have to keep working on
this and and what you've been doing
isn't working so you need to change
something's got to change and what she's
been doing isn't working so it's gonna
change and maybe she doesn't want to go
to a marriage counselor with you but if
I were you I'd discover myself because
all this is is like marriage training
how to speak woman start with
vulnerability start with I'm sorry